let's talk about how women behave during
divorce so
this is infused in here because this is
going to happen to 50 of the people
that are going to get married if you're
a second time around marriage i think
the number is higher like 75 to 80
percent
third time's even higher than that it's
just a disaster
um anyway so how women behave
so between the combination of family law
and female nature women are motivated to
behave incredibly poorly
to the father of their children during
the divorce i'm assuming that there's
children in the equation because really
there's no point in getting married if
you're not going to have kids
it's it's utterly pointless in my view
don't do it i'll
i'll tell you straight up rich should i
get married and not have kids no don't
do it
it's stupid there are significant
female-centric financial rewards
that are that have been well written
into family law encouraging them to be
the sole custodial parent of the
children
by becoming the parent that is a primary
custody of the children that gives
primary custody
or care to the kids money and all
decision making capacity goes to the
parent awarded custody which eight times
out of ten
is the woman now i i'm gonna pause for a
second to say
i'm not a lawyer if you need legal
advice talk to a lawyer
where you live and in fact before any of
you muppets out there decide to get
married
you need to screw your head on right and
buy at least an hour of time from a
family lawyer that deals with divorce on
a regular basis where you live to find
out
what you could be marching into you want
to know exactly what the slaughterhouse
looks like
so you can make an informed decision you
may want to move to another state or
province that's more favorable to
fathers if you're hell-bent on getting
married
that might be one of the conditions that
has to be met and if she's truly in your
frame
and sees you as her best possible option
she will follow
right but this is just something that i
wanted to pause for the cause and
clarify for you
so eight times out of ten women still
get custody of the kids
um now women are opportunistic by nature
it's hardwired into them it's
part of the reason why we as sapiens are
successful species right
uh this is what solipsism meant without
opportunism her children were less
likely to survive you can't blame women
for this
it's an evolved survival mechanism the
problem though
is that everything in family law is
built
into it to be able to take advantage and
optimize
that part of female nature right i mean
it's no surprise
anyway so women need the skill obviously
to find the best provisioning mate to
optimize their hypergamy if you give
someone that's naturally opportunistic
incentive to benefit from at another's
expense then guess what
they will do it okay part of human
nature people are self-interested
men and women women are more you know
from the sense of solipsism
you know you can always tell the
differences
from this phrase because when they tell
women
to to do something that's right what
they say is they do
you do what's right for you girl right
but when they tell
guys to do what's right they say you got
to do what's right you know
basically like stand up be the stand-up
kind of guy
and take one for the team right because
guys are disposable women are the
protect success because you know sex is
just the way that it is
um oh i skipped the part on marriage
actually so
i just remembered so stephanie coots
wrote a book on
the uh i think it's called either the
origin of marriage or the history of
marriage and several pages back i'm not
going to scroll
you'll find it when you read the book
it's something that i recommend that you
check out
but the original purpose of marriage had
nothing to do with love it was all about
the acquisition of in-laws
meaning you weren't going to survive you
weren't going to do well in the world if
you weren't part of a tribe
where you had in-laws that had certain
capacities and skills and capabilities
and strengths
and financial resources and influence
that was what marriage was all about it
was about the acquisition of
in-laws you wanted bigger farmland more
oxen more goats
larger plot to pop out all your
your kids you know to sire those
children of course
and it's interesting when i was going
through that book there was
actually quite a few times throughout
history where men by default
had custody of the kids if there was
ever a divorce um
everything that they went through uh
legal records uh journals
diaries all that stuff nobody got
married for love
it was all about the acquisition of
in-laws that was that you know that took
a back seat
if that existed then that was great but
for the most part it didn't
right so you just have to understand
that so it's only in
in recent history like today over the
last i'm going to say
25 to 50 odd years that female
opportunism has had the full backing of
the state behind it as
family law right prior to 150 years ago
just didn't exist
and when the father got custody of the
children
he would often retain all the family
assets including what she brought to the
table
they've they've completely flipped the
script on this go read marriage of
history interesting book
very very interesting book
now this is this is one of the problems
um with the whole divorce situation is
once the custodial parent has
those rights they they can make
unilateral decisions without the other
parent's consent let me translate that
for you they can do whatever the hell
they want without the other parents
input
so you contribute fifty percent of the
dna
to the child's equation but you have no
say
in medical procedures uh what school
they go to
what religion they follow where they
live
any number of things can happen
depending on where you live up to
including
changing the kid's last name to the new
guy that gets brought into the family
uh you know the brady bunch is then
correct you know created they try to
infuse families what they call it
blending the family he brings two or
three uh you know until from his prior
marriage
you know she's of course got your kids
most of the time he ends up seeing your
kids more than you do
and they end up with his last name stuff
like this happens
you know a lot of what are you talking
about that's not that's not cut it
happens
it happens more than you think right i
mean there's so many different scenarios
that i could go through here
to kind of um you know expand and dive
down on it but
this would literally take six hours for
me to list them all but
here we go um so we've talked about
custodial rights
how women are incented to behave badly
during the divorce let's talk about
alimony
also known as maintenance it's the first
level of responsibility
men often pay their ex-wives so if
you're the breadwinner in the house
and she doesn't work or earns
significantly less like you said stay
home look after the kids
um you know we've got three of them
you're going to stay home and and raise
them until they go to school
um the problem that you run into i mean
the benefit of course is that's the best
way to raise them
um statistically speaking i suppose
based on the evidence that i've seen
anyway
but then you run into the problem of if
she wants to divorce your ass seven
years down the road when
that's usually the first round and uh
guess what she's been the primary
caregiver she's been at home
you know raising the kids she hasn't
worked you're on the hook for alimony
depending on where you live in the world
you could be on the hook for alimony for
life
right um there's there's all kinds of
complications that come with that
and it's not it's not just you know
basic living expenses like
oh here's three thousand dollars a month
and uh you know you have your apartment
paid for and you know you're good to go
you don't have to worry about everything
everything's good
sweetheart no no no no no no no no no
no if you're making a lot of money
you're making half a million a million
dollars a year
and uh you get divorced and you got to
pay alimony
you're going to meet you're going to be
maintaining the lifestyle that she had
while she was married after you get
divorced
you're essentially paying for your
lifestyle today
times two okay you're gonna have to
maintain two homes i mean
most guys end up downsizing their home
or or buying some shittier place or they
move out of the matrimony home and let
her keep it
but you're maintaining two homes if she
didn't work if she didn't have the
ability to work so
that's a very expensive cost you know
all these strong
independent women that don't need no man
all of a sudden
need no man when he's got the ability to
pay 20
000 a month in alimony to her they need
that man then
right but any other time they don't need
no man right
again you have 100 percent
responsibility even after divorce now
after you break up you go back 500 years
ago you didn't have any responsibility
if you got divorced
she'd have to figure it out on her own
she'd go back to her family work in a
brothel not your problem
you'd end up having all the assets and
custody of the kids
today this is just the tip of the
iceberg we're just talking about alimony
here right now
let me grab this super chat laughing
lark
in mad men when betty wanted to divorce
don her lawyer warned her that she would
lose the kids and her home that was the
60s
yeah so if if that's the way they did in
the 60s it wasn't that far off that
you know divorce was not attracted to
women today it's very attractive to
women i'm going to show you
an exact example here how the state how
the government actually encourages women
to divorce men and become single mothers
anyway so you're up keep so you're
responsible for the upkeep of the
standard of living after the marriage
ends doesn't matter
you know what that looks like it's it's
not you know well i feel like giving her
3 000 it's no you have to maintain
her standard of living after that could
be for
life you know in some places like
california if you were married for 10
years plus it could be for life
let's talk about child support child
support is paid to the custodial parent
to cover the cost
of raising the children now contrary to
proper belief the payment amount is not
based on what the children actually need
to survive
so your father you're taking care of
i don't know a three-year-old you got
transitional diapers a little bit of
clothes maybe a little bit of child
care maybe your total uh monthly cost
food you know meals you know
maybe your total monthly cost is a
thousand dollars a month okay for
child support for that child it's not
based on what the child actually needs
to survive
it's rather based on state issue tables
so
i put here in uh the chapter i had a
friend that calculated that during his
marriage his monthly cost look after his
kid for food and everything was around
500 bucks a month
the state issued child support tables
however compelled them to legally
enforceably pay 4367
every single month child support for the
most part goes to the mother
not the kids so we have the first layer
which is alimony
which goes to the mother then child
support even if the kid needs a thousand
dollars a month
okay to to survive you know for its
necessities and of course you're going
to want to
pay that it's your child right why the
hell wouldn't you want to pay it
but if the child needs a thousand why
aren't you paying a thousand why are you
paying four thousand three hundred sixty
seven
where does the extra three thousand
three hundred sixty seven dollars go to
and there's no accounting for it by the
way okay
there's there's no accounting for her to
you
as a father with what she does with that
money
oh by the way it's after-tax money
right so the tax consequences here
anyway in
canada are very very high so
take it for what it is anyway so that's
the way child support works generally
speaking on a balance of probabilities
uh let's talk about matrimonial assets
so matrimonial assets are divided after
the knot is untied usually 50 50.
so you take everything that you acquired
through the course of the marriage
you shove it in a big pile you cut it
down the middle you take half
piss off this is mine and you stay on
your side that's basically
generally speaking the way that it works
if you've been married for a long time
and you don't have a prenup
that uh speaks to that issue
uh although places like australia where
more than half of the assets
can be awarded to the mother shocking
right
so every asset you acquire before after
your nuptials goes into policy splitting
them okay we talked about that
now prenuptials can in some areas
protect this
but they're not very effective in being
honest you have to have a prenup
ideally a post nup meaning after you
sign your nuptials you have
a another agreement that basically says
nothing's changed we're still agreeing
to this we've signed
we still love each other we hope nothing
changes but this is
you know this is the rule law that we're
gonna follow now here's the problem
though
if you're all of a sudden like okay
let's go have those three kids
um and then i'm gonna go to work and i'm
gonna bring home the bacon and she's
gonna cook it up and she raises the kids
and she's done that for eight to ten
years and again she hasn't worked
and of course uh the argument that the
state will make is well
her skills are out of date you know
she's no longer able to go
into the workforce and make the fifty
thousand dollars a year she was before
she got married
because ten years have passed she's
raised three kids her skill set has
changed she needs to update her skills
she can't afford to do that so let's put
her on alimony and child support and
we'll let
you know the pleb over here take care of
all that while he watches her
alienate him from the kids that's
usually what ends up happening
but anyway so the prenup
going back to that if that 10 years has
passed
and you haven't refreshed it or you
haven't updated it which most people
don't do
i mean it just doesn't happen then guess
what it's worthless
it's it's like toilet paper it's
basically worth toilet paper okay
um the state doesn't deprive women
and what they call the best interests of
the children but
they're not really looking after the
best interests of the children
they don't let women uh fall flat on
their feet
right we can't let women fall fat on
their fleet fall flat on their feet
you know um i think i was watching
roller the other day on a
cast and he said something to the agree
of we treat women like children today
and he's right he's not wrong because
they won't let women fall flat on their
feet and figure it out you know for
themselves if he has the financial
resources guess what
let's milk them and transfer them over
here right
but it's it's in excess it's excessive
is the point that i'm making right um
you know these strong independent women
that don't need no man
if they can get a job or at least get by
on a bare minimum of three or four
thousand dollars
until they figure something out and they
don't make their problems
men's problems then guess what they're
less likely to want to behave badly
especially during the course of divorce
or even in the marriage
and ruin things but there's no incentive
for women to behave well they can behave
they can go and bang every dude they
want they can bang your kids
soccer coach the guy that teaches them
jiu jitsu
she can go and bang the yoga instructor
she can she can go on a tear and ride
the carousel for all she wants and
videotape and have it playing on the tv
when he comes home
and that still doesn't change any of
this none of it changes
none of it no fault divorce right anyway
since men rarely stay home to raise the
the kids and women are hypergamous in
their mate selection meaning they always
marry up
you can always expect the guy
to transfer wealth over to her through
the state
and it's excessive again
okay again hypergamy doesn't care if she
vows would love to be with you and
richer or poorer in sickness and health
till death do us part does not care okay
let's see what else we got here
divorce this is an interesting one
because mackenzie bezos was one that got
divorced earlier this year or last year
whenever it was but she became the
richest woman in the world by way of
divorce
divorce not career or entrepreneurship
is statistically
still the number one way that women
acquire their wealth today
right strong independent women acquiring
their wealth through divorce
they didn't have it before they got into
it but they don't definitely get it
on the exit strategy so you can see how
women are not
encouraged to behave well and to stay
married to men
don't like it you know you think you can
do better somewhere else you go girl you
do what's right for you
divorce is asked take half of all the
[ __ ] custody of the kids you'll make all
the decisions you'll get alimony and
child support
you go find the new guy right you can do
better
you